but tonight is McDonald immunity hi I'm
Evan and I'm here in my motherland South
Korea so with a few of my American
friends we are about to try some Korean
McDonald's aka next when I did the items
of the menu here I heard it's really
crazy it's a lot different from the ones
in America let's see if you like it
we're having Green McDonald's leaving
the first time you for the first time in
115 years I think
not a huge fast food cars so though I
visit Korea actually never visit
McDonald's this is as new to me as it is
to you I've been had that much
McDonald's probably had it when I was a
kid a couple times willing to try it
because we're in Korea I think I'm gonna
enjoy Korean McDonald's because I'm all
about those options I've been dying to
try it let's do this double bulgogi
burger wow this is saucy kind of looks
like sausage you know what do you
picture bulgogi
it's like sliced diced shredded meat I'm
expecting to see like an Arby's roast
beef burger it does smell approval to go
it's a double sausage patty burger with
some bulgogi marinade on it it's pretty
good yeah it's I don't hate it
not bad but not bulgogi it is really
salty though it is a little bit too
salty for me and I'm a salty boy I'd say
saucy boy in Korean so salsa boy the
supreme shrimp burger Koreans are really
into their shrimpy snacks than their
squiding snacks I gotta tell you
something Stephen what I'm allergic to
shrimp just fine giveth me
[Music]
it is so shrimpy inside wait there's
actual shrimp in there it's actually a
shrimp I'll get a wide being like a
paste this is official fillet of Korea
it's got that popcorn shrimp taste that
battered fried shrimp and peel shrimpy
with spicy Shanghai chicken burger got a
big old chicken thing happening this is
probably the only pheasant burger that
the patties actually bigger than the bun
okay
it is a little bit spicy but all the
spice is coming from inside the chicken
you can taste the chicken a lot better
than you can taste the chicken in
America the chicken is not mushy at all
the texture of the meat is there it's
general chili spiciness not like pepper
spice you know you're not getting like a
different flavor like you would get from
a whole opinion or something like that
I got that spice coming in like on the
back when I chewed in it's like flirting
with my mouth girl does that say Shura
trust me dresser is a serious amount of
the cinnamon sugar on here you know it's
nothing on a churro
but I would buy it just because it's
good there's three different sauce
options strawberry which is apparently
radioactive it's like alien blood very
sweet like if you just melted down some
strawberry lollipops that's this dip
it's like caramel oh that's thick it's
probably the way to go with this one I
would just eat it plain to be honest
yeah it's already sweet it's so ready
and so dense I do enjoy it did he say
chocolate in Korean on a chocolate
distinctly Hershey syrup exactly what I
was gonna say okay over Alma I like new
enjoy McDonald I mean I was an agent
more upscale more luxurious I enjoyed
the foods that were here the spicy
chicken burger I think it was really
great if these burgers were presented in
America oh yeah I feel crazy right now
[Music]